i am deeply grateful for the addresses
of condolence
which so movingly paid tribute
to our late sovereign my beloved mother
the queen
sinneth of
kamri
and
fruit
through all the years of her reign
the land of wales
could not have been closer to my
mother's heart
roy
i know she took immense pride
in your many great achievements
even as she also felt with you deeply in
in time of sorrow
it must surely be counted the greatest
privilege to belong to a land that could
inspire such devotion
i am resolved to honor that selfless
example
in the spirit of the words
by which i have always tried to live my
own life
ich dion
i serve
an hour
b
for mob william
and durbin
a title
my
ganzo ev
garriad duven
at gumry
i take up
my new duties with immense gratitude
for the privilege
of having been able to serve as prince
of wales
that ancient title
dating from the time
of those great welsh rulers
like clewell and ap griffith
whose memory is still rightly honoured
i now pass to my son william
whose love for this corner of the earth
is made all the greater by the years he
himself has spent here
bonodiggion
roulade
arbenig han
having visited the senate regularly
since it was founded
and having heard your heartfelt words
today
i know we all share the deepest
commitment for the welfare to the
welfare
of the people of this land
and that we will all continue to work
together to that end
thank you your majesty for your words to
the senate and to wales